very interesting story and uh and and
one of the things that makes it
interesting is that it's one of the
few Uh current events with with huge
implications that where where the
political sides are not exactly clear
like they this this is not this is this
one is not really the political teams
are are aren't clear you know um and
that doesn't happen very often um so
here's here it is ABC News as a report a
jury has found Jennifer Crumbley the
mother of Michigan school shooter Ethan
Crumbley guilty of involuntary
manslaughter in connection with the
shooting deaths of four students at
Oxford High School in November of 2021
Crumbley uh Crumbley was found guilty of
four counts of involuntary manslaughter
in connection with the shooting uh one
for each victim Madison Baldwin Tate
Meyer Justin Schilling and Hannah St
Juliana the jury deliberated for roughly
11 hours uh Jennifer and James Crumbley
are a rare case of parents being charged
in connection with a shooting carried
out by their son James Crumbley who also
faces four counts of involuntary
manslaughter will have a separate trial
in
March um and so they are they're going
in jail for the fact that their son
committed a school
shooting now so this is uh a very
important case um and I think
that you know it's obviously getting
some attention I think it's should
actually be getting more attention than
it is and I'm not sure if everybody
quite
grasps just how vast the implications
are because this is really an
unprecedented moment in the history of
the American legal system the article
said this is a rare case where the
parent of a school shooter is charged
I'm pretty sure it's the first case um
so
a a new precedent is being set there's a
new precedent being set here and I think
the precedent is troubling um
I think it's quite troubling now listen
Jennifer Crumbley and her husband by all
accounts based on everything we heard in
the trial based on everything we've seen
not to mention obviously just based on
the fact of what their son
did So based on all that we can
establish Beyond any reasonable doubt
that these are bad parents H you know
that of course they failed in
spectacular fashion in their basic
parenting duties um they were not
just to call them bad parents would be
an understatement and there's no denying
that no disputing it I certainly don't
dispute it and that's why on a visceral
emotional
level uh I understand the people that
are cheering this
verdict and from what I've seen
anecdotally I don't know what the
surveys would say but I've seen
anecdotally just on social media it
seems like most of the people who'
reacted to the story and the verdict
yesterday are in favor of it that's
that's what it seems certainly there's a
lot of people who are happy about the
verdict uh and if I'm being guided
purely by my feelings of disgust towards
uh parents who apparently didn't even
attempt to do their job as parents then
and I'm being Guided by that then I
would say hell yeah go rot in prison you
deserve it and if I was God forbid you
know I was a parent who who lost a child
in a circumstance like this even more
I I would
probably
um
be want the parents to to suffer for
their failures as parents so I get all
that and I have no interest in defending
the parenting job that these two people
did there's no defending
it and and I I would I would also say
that it seems clear to
me uh that it is it is at least
partially their fault that their son
went off and murdered innocent people
so if you're blaming them at least
partially for what happened I think that
makes sense yeah I think they are at
least partially to
blame all of that is
true however with all of that said I
just have extreme reservations about it
and and um and I'll give you two things
to think about
here first of
all the prosecutor's case even though it
was ultimately successful he
prevailed but really the the that the
state was making here it makes no
logical sense and there are a few
reasons for that but the main one the
big one to my mind is that they charged
Ethan Crumbley the shooter as an
adult right now why is that significant
well because in charging him as an adult
and he committed the crime when he was
uh I think
15 but they charge him as an adult and I
agree with that I agree with charging as
an adult for a crime like
this now 15 is not an adult but but for
a crime like this I think you have to
like what else are you going to do send
him to juvenile detention and let him
out in in five years like you can't do
that
so I agree with the move I think it's
the right move in this case and uh if
you have someone even at 15 who commits
a crime of this sort well they they just
have to go away forever there there's no
way that you could ever like it's we
cannot contemplate a future where
someone who
murdered uh who's committed mass murder
is is walking
free if you're like me there's not a day
that goes by that you don't call or text
someone you care about I'm constantly
chatting on the phone myself and my
friends at Pure Talk are making it
easier and more affordable to connect
with the most important people in your
life pure talk gives you the phenomenal
coverage that you want on America's Most
Dependable 5G Network it's the same
coverage you know and love but for half
the price of the other guys with
unlimited plans starting at just 20
bucks a month the average family saves
almost 1,000 bucks a year a veteran
owned company Pure Talk raised $10
million towards veteran debt last year
alone what's more P Talk's customer
service team is located right here in
the US and can help you make the switch
in as little as 10 minutes I challenge
you to stand with a company that
Champions your values today so go to
your go to Pur talk.com Walsh right now
you can save an additional 50% on your
first month there but you got to go to
Pur talk.com Walsh to save on wireless
with a company you can be proud to spend
your money with again Pur talk.com SL
Walsh today
but in charging him as an adult the
state is saying that he is fully
culpable fully competent and fully
responsible for his own actions that's
what it means to charge him as an adult
that's the argument the state is
making and and they made it successfully
he got life in
prison but then when they turn around in
charge his
parents blaming them in part for their
child's actionss they're they're they
are also then arguing by extension at
the exact same time that Ethan Crumbley
was not fully C culpable and not fully
responsible for his
actions because to blame the parents to
any degree at all is to say that they
had some sort of control over this
situation which would mean that that
that the child is not responsible for
his actions at least not
completely so how can they argue both
how can both be true how can he be fully
culpable but not fully culpable at the
exact same
time um how can Ethan be an adult
responsible for his own actions while at
the same time being a child Whose
actions are partially the fault of his
parents whose parents who by the way
even if they were negligent in the
extreme and they were they still didn't
know that he was going to commit the
crime now like obviously if if the
parents have direct knowledge that a
crime is going to be committed and they
don't try to prevent it um or they facil
facilitate the commission of the crime
well clearly that that's there's no
controversy
there uh but that's not exactly the
claim here the claim here is like they
should have seen it coming they saw
warning signs they knew that he was
troubled they knew that he had written
things on about killing people but but
that's not the same as saying like he to
Mom and Dad I'm going to go commit this
shooting and they said okay see you
later like it that didn't
happen um
so the claim again is that they were
really bad parents basically and they
needed to take better care of their
child which is all again true but I just
don't see how you can argue that and at
the same time argue that the child is is
an adult like it it seems like it's got
to be one or the other in order for the
charges to make sense
logically and and yet they didn't make
sense and they contradicted uh but they
got the conviction on both counts so I
want you to think think about the
implications here because this is the
this is the
the the really the biggest issue is what
is the limiting
principle we all agree that the crumbl
were bad parents
um and I think we all agree that if they
were better parents probably this crime
never would have been committed we can't
say that for sure because people are
even a kid is like their own human being
with their own mind and and you know
it's it's it's plausible that you could
be a perfect parent basically and still
end up with a kid who does something
horrible it's like it's unlikely but it
could
happen so but probably if they had been
better parents this wouldn't have
happened
um but that same argument applies just
as well to many thousands of parents who
are still walking free today I mean it
stands to reason that a large majority
of the violent criminals in prison right
now have parents who were at least at
least as negligent and incompetent and
disinterested
as the crumblies were so put it out of
the way as as a percentage as a
percentage how many mass murderers
serial killers and gang bangers do you
think had good attentive
parents like does anyone think that it's
more than 10% I mean 10% is extremely
generous
estimate um it's pretty obvious that
like the the Armed robber who is uh
walking into a gas station in some city
as we speak right now stealing
everything from the register and then
maybe shooting the cashier just for the
sake of it on the way out the door um
it's pretty obvious that that person
almost certainly has parents who are at
best were negligent U most likely the
father is completely absent so that's
total 100% negligence and the mother is
just not interested in doing anything
that could be described as actually
mothering her
child so my question is are are we
charging all of those parents too are we
going to round up hundreds of thousands
of parents potentially and charge them
for their failures their failure to do
anything at all to prevent their
children from becoming violent
criminals me just
imagine a lot of the a lot of these
criminal violent criminals in the inner
city like imagine what their home life
is like imagine what kind of parenting
is being done
here
um some people don't have to imagine it
because they've seen this kind of thing
firsthand and and and you know it's the
kind of parent it's like very easy you
could see the way the child's parented
and you get well yeah of course that
kid's going to end up being a
criminal and yet we never go back to the
parents and charge them when the
inevitable
occurs uh even though crumblies yeah
it's partially their fault I I
agree 90% of violent criminals in prison
right now it's also partially the fault
of the parents so I I don't see how we
justify only charging these parents and
not all of the others who are at least
just as
culpable but then other on the other
hand do I actually want to see all those
parents charged probably not because
then now we've really opened a can of
worms that um I don't know how you close
it again and again I don't know where
the limiting principle
is um once you start charging parents
criminally for the Terrible Things their
kids do it
just you know eventually 90% of the
parents in the country are in jail I I
you know that's that's where it leads
and
um and I don't I don't think that this
has all been thought I just I don't
think anyone's really thinking Some
people have thought this through but I
don't think that uh that we've quite
faced the implications here enough hey
YouTube thanks for listening to the show
if you'd like access to my full show
with no ads you should go to
dailywire.com and use promo code Walsh
to get two months free on all annual
plans see you there